[Música]
las fuerzas rusas cierran kiev la
capital de ucrania que ya es asediada
por dos de sus extremos entretanto el
posible ataque sobre la ciudad de odessa
principal puerto ucraniano sobre el mar
negro mantiene en vilo a una población
con numerosos vínculos históricos
familiares y comerciales con sus vecinos
rusos tenemos reportes
la agencia de la onu para los refugiados
elevó a 28 millones la cifra de
migrantes ucranianos en 19 días de
guerra de seguir este ritmo acnur
advierte que se superarán las
estimaciones iniciales de 4 millones de
refugiados
desde que empezó la invasión rusa y
ucrania el kremlin empezó una campaña
contra la información sobre el conflicto
los reporteros en rusia que usan la
palabra guerra o invasión están en
riesgo de ser arrestados una productora
se atrevió a hacerlo se lo contamos
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 6 rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos las fuerzas de rusia siguen
bombardeando varias ciudades incluyendo
kiev y sus alrededores
en odessa el principal puerto ucraniano
sobre el mar negro la mayoría de la
población habla ruso y muchos tienen
lazos familiares y comerciales con ese
país por eso la invasión ordenada por
vladimir putin y un posible ataque a la
ciudad les ha provocado intranquilidad
muchos piensan que la relación con rusia
nunca podrá volver a ser igual informe
de nuestros enviados especiales catalina
gómez ángel y uriol andrés guy art
la catedral ortodoxa de esa está más
llena que de costumbre la invasión rusa
ha llevado a que muchos más feligreses
la visiten para pedir por el fin de la
guerra y la protección de su ciudad
es mi mundo
toda la comunidad religiosa de dureza
está unida actualmente con una misma
idea y acciones para proteger el país y
niell
el dolor del arzobispo y odiar es
visible la iglesia ortodoxa ucraniana se
ha visto atrapada en esta guerra condenó
la invasión rusa desde el primer día y
pidió al patriarca de la iglesia de
moscú para que intercediera ante
vladimir putin sus acciones no han
tenido éxito en la agresión nos duele el
doble pues viene de un pueblo con el que
compartimos la misma perú la del millón
de habitantes yo de esa más del 80% son
ortodoxos el idioma mayoritario es el
ruso y miles de familias están
repartidas a ambos lados de la frontera
este es el caso de este grupo de amigos
que discuten sobre la invasión
tengo nacionalidad ucraniana pero nací y
crecí en una comunidad de ruso parlante
nunca me cabe en la cabeza que esto esté
pasando
[Música]
vladimir nación ucrania cuando era parte
de la unión soviética pero para víctor
las relaciones aún más estrecha nación
rusia donde vive gran parte de su
familia muy bien ya que usted ve en mi
cara la de un hombre que ha sido
reprimido porque habla ruso esto es
absurdo y muy grande en estas calles
pocos olvidan que una de las
justificaciones de putin para invadir
ucrania era la defensa de los rusos
parlantes y no estás vivo aquí todos
hablan ruso
usted puede chequear en la iglesia solo
dos misas en ucrania no son más ni
granger o de esas una ciudad cosmopolita
acoge más de 120 nacionalidades y
decenas de confesiones que se han unido
para dar apoyo a quienes resisten en la
ciudad como en esta iglesia católica
porque no tenemos por ser minoría sino
por la guerra que es terrible ahora
en estos cultos saben bien que una
victoria rusa significará la pérdida de
la libertad una pesadilla que nadie
quiere enfrentar
la agencia de la onu para los refugiados
elevó a 28 millones la cifra de
migrantes ucranianos que huyen de la
guerra acnur estima que de seguir este
ritmo el éxodo de ucranianos podría
superar los 4 millones que se estimaron
en un principio para el mayor éxodo en
europa desde la segunda guerra mundial
hoy el presidente de rusia vladimir
putin justifica la invasión con el
argumento de desnazificación ya sin
embargo centros de memoria de auschwitz
están acogiendo ucranianos
muy cerca de auschwitz en polonia hay un
centro de educación juvenil dedicado a
preservar los recuerdos del holocausto y
de la 2ª guerra mundial
allí acogen a los ucranianos que huyen
de la guerra en un mensaje contra la
retórica de vladimir putin que justificó
la inversión en la supuesta
desnazificación de ucrania tacna alphand
es desde el primer día después del
inicio de la guerra hemos puesto todas
nuestras habitaciones a su disposición
haremos todo lo posible para que la
gente de ucrania tenga un lugar para
quedarse aquí el mayor tiempo posible
hasta ahora han acogido a 50 ucranianos
y han repartido dos mil comidas un lugar
seguro para personas como pavel que lo
han dejado todo y
la gente se está muriendo es horrible lo
que está pasando en este momento y
espero que todo termine pronto porque me
fui de mi casa me fui para no ser
bombardeado espero que termine lo antes
posible no sé qué hacer ni dónde vivir
dejé mi vida ahí
hay uno preguntas similares se hace
tamil a que huyó con sus tres hijos y su
madre
creo que habrá cielos pacíficos sobre
nuestras cabezas pero ahora no sé qué
hacer ni a dónde ir ni qué pasará
después
cerca de 3 millones de ucranianos han
salido del país en el mayor éxodo desde
la segunda guerra mundial de todos los
países polonia es el que más ha recibido
con 17 millones y en esta zona auschwitz
ejemplifica la mayor barbarie sucedida
en europa es donde en el pasado murieron
más de un millón de personas en su
mayoría judíos pero ahora es un lugar
para dejar atrás la guerra al menos por
el momento
tras el llamado del presidente de
ucrania volodymyr selenski unos 20.000
voluntarios extranjeros se han alistado
para combatir entre estos voluntarios
varios son franceses algunos se unen a
las filas de los trabajadores
humanitarios otros optan por tomar las
armas y unirse a la legión quienes son
estos franceses que van a la guerra a
1.800 kilómetros de su casa
está a punto de acabar su maleta se
reúne el día siguiente con su grupo para
salir hacia ucrania lo que me lleve
también es un abrigo militar una parca
de está forrada es para temperaturas muy
frías eso es de un sargento o algo así
así que no lo guardo ningún signo
distintivo de pertenencia a un ejército
ni nada por el estilo dinámico acceso a
sería es una figura de los chalecos
amarillos piensa ayudar en ucrania junto
a los trabajadores humanitarios pero no
descarta tomar las armas
es europa europa del este vemos las
imágenes es terrible hay muertos hay
familias hay dos millones de exiliados
así que sentí esta llamada para ir allí
ir al terreno para ayudarles para poder
hacer algo solía salir a la calle para
hacer frente a los problemas de francia
hay problemas allí así que voy a ir la
problemática donde no tiene experiencia
en zonas de guerra confía en la de sus
compañeros de viaje especializados en la
ayuda médica de urgencia y así los
conoció a través de redes sociales pero
no en persona ellos ya están en camino
al igual que terry respondieron a la
llamada del president excelentes clic
uno de ellos luchó en las fuerzas
francesas y ahora trabaja detrás de un
escritorio el otro hace trabajos
ocasionales
cuando te dices a ti mismo que ya no
tienes nada que perder y que tú también
podrías vivirlo porque no ir sobre todo
ahora no hay excusas podemos ir podemos
ayudarle
quieren permanecer en el anonimato sus
familias no saben que se van a combatir
es un honor poder ir allí y luchar con
ellos y creo que si un día ocurriera en
francia me alegraría mucho que otros
países así vinieran a ayudarnos
estaremos muy contentos de tenerlos
chile y este pequeño grupo de
combatientes voluntarios esperan llegar
al vivo y luego aquí es lo antes posible
sus contactos locales les habían
prometido un cruce simplificado de la
frontera ucraniana pero 72 horas después
de su llegada seguían bloqueados en
polonia desde el inicio de la invasión a
ucrania vladímir putin ha emprendido
también una campaña contra los medios de
comunicación
los que informan la realidad sobre lo
que está sucediendo pueden ser
arrestados pese a eso una productora de
televisión tomó un gran riesgo y habló
en contra de la guerra para decirle a la
audiencia que les estaban mintiendo el
canal uno al que pertenecía a la
periodista confirmó que abrirá una
investigación y que fue detenida
lo que está sucediendo ahora en ucrania
es un crimen y rusia es el país agresor
la responsabilidad de esa agresión recae
en la conciencia de un solo hombre y ese
hombre es vladimir putin
mi padre es ucraniano mi madre es rusa
nunca fueron enemigos el collar en mi
cuello es un símbolo de que rusia debe
detener inmediatamente la guerra
nuestras naciones hermanas podrán
entonces aún hacer la paz
lamentablemente durante los últimos años
trabajé en el canal 1 difundir la
propaganda del kremlin y me avergüenzo
mucho de esto me avergüenza haber
permitido que se dijeran mentiras en las
pantallas de televisión la vergüenza
haber permitido que se engañar a los
rusos en 2014 nos quedamos en silencio
cuando todo empezó nos salimos a
protestar con el kremlin en veneno anna
barniz
hasta aquí este informativo sigan con
nosotros
[Música]